уже за лічені хвилини військова форма
зміниться з цинічним костюмом спочатку
повномасштабної війни актор Євген Нищук
став на захист України але й дорогу до
рідного театру в Києві не забув тут його
зустрічають як справжнього героя
[музика]
на фронт не означає піти з театру каже
актору у середньому двічі на місяць Він
приїжджає до столиці на вистави цього
разу грає Михайла у п'єсі Івана Франка
Украдене щастя
на землі з тим що нас розлучив
наперекір тим що
вкрали наше щастя
це ні майже
100 і сьогодні
століттями
вони крали нашу нашу історію нашої
ідентичність вони привласнювали собі
наших героїв в наші здобутки вони мурили
нас голодом вони нищили нашу козацьку
державу як Прототип і спроби створити
власне свою власну Українську державу це
багатостолітня
боротьба
проти українського народу проти
Української держави і
нарешті це
це стало так дуже
не заплутано не завоульовано а от так от
відкрито коли полетіли ракети по всій
Україні за сцена
рієм повертається з війни на яку його
відправили не за власною волею старий
побратими
[музика]
Та хіба ж ти мене не впізнав
Михайло
Гурман та у реальному житті все дещо
інакше одразу після вторгнення
Російської Федерації Євген Нищук попри
відсутність військового досвіду
добровольцем пішов захищати рідну землю
а вже згодом офіційно приєднався до лав
збройних сил України Я був як
доброволець якраз на лінії Ірпінь Буча
стоянка
Гостомель і так далі згодом ми трішки ще
поїхали на чернігівщину І після того
постало питання
командування самого батальйону
добровольчого Чи згодні ми
переміщатися в інші частини куточків
України чи ми тільки залишаємося в Києві
і Ну я і мої побратими з якими ми вже
так спонтанно організували групу
прийняли
порушення їхати їхати далі І це став
південь який я дуже добре знаю в силу
того що і був любив дуже буватий тепер
тут народний артист актор а там на
південному напрямку захисник
аеророзвідник проте й В окопах війна з
мистецтвом пліч-о-пліч
навіть янголи завмерли в небі
як театральних зал
небо теж полюбляє сипати
снігом градом дощем разом із побратимами
вишукуючи скупчення техніки ворога на
миколаївщині та Херсонщині Євген Нищук
наближав знаковий для кожного українця
день 11 листопада
2022 року звільнення Херсона від
російських загарбників
[оплески]
і від зустрічі простих людей які просто
ну це не забудьте заради такого дійсно
можна можна воювати можна перевертати
гори бо так як сприймали
воїнів українських в
деокупованих територіях так в Херсоні
зокрема це просто щось неймовірне і їм
нічого було не потрібно Так вони
звичайно що їм як і всій Україні
потрібно і тепло і світло і їжа і так
далі але Це для них не мало жодного
значення там хлопці щось назбирали Ми
там їм привезли але вони кажуть нам це
не важливо ми ми все знайдемо головне -
це це Воля Євген Нищук вперше опиняється
там де твориться історія багатьом він
запам'ятався як один із символів
помаранчевої революції та революції
гідності той самий Голос майдану Майдан
зупинив на якийсь час ось це
широкомасштабне вторгнення бо воно би
було просто як здача взагалі Тобто ми би
навіть не встигли оговтатись але Майдан
якраз зупинив так вони це
продемонстрували через анексію Криму так
через вторгнення на східні терени
Української держави Донецьк Луганськ але
вони все одно призупинилися
призупинилися на 8 років і все ж таки
вони прийшли до того що що вони
вторглися повністю актор воїн впевнений
вторгнення Фатальна помилка росіян адже
боротися за свою свободу і незалежність
українцям доводиться не вперше ми маємо
історичну традицію славного воїнства Так
ми всі
не припиняємо вчитися і час від часу
якщо з'являється та чи інша техніка
взагалі я говорю про про різні види
військ так всі проходять навчання
два тижні місяці Так але це дуже швидко
це те що у натівських
навчаннях відбувається побільше як року
наші опановуються за значно коротший
термін вистава Украдене щастя
завершується незмінно трагічно як колись
і написав Іван Франко
Кажу хто ти нічого мені зовсім добрий Та
це лише вистава а одразу після неї Євген
Нищук повернеться на фронт Де разом із
побратимами наближатиме перемогу України
ми відкрили себе для всього світу
і це Це дивовижно це ну це сильна віра
тому ця віра в те що ми будемо мати цю
велику омріяну країну вона дає
можливість все витримати Не виснажитися
ну і власне перемогти